bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions karine vais chez golovkov
quelle est votre réaction suite aux
propos tenus par joe biden à l'égard de
vladimir poutine
bonsoir effectivement c'est quand même
assez surprenant de la part d'un
président américain d'entendre de tels
propos à l'égard du président d'un autre
pays peut dire que c'est une violation
totale de toutes les règles de la
diplomatie qui existe à ce jour et pour
comprendre mon avis l'importance de ces
propos il faut comprendre aussi toute la
mise en scène qui a derrière c'est à
dire que ça tombe au moment où les
services de renseignement américains
déclassifie un soi-disant rapport qui
intervient dans ce processus de
légitimation des élections de byden
parce qu'il en a très sérieusement
besoin donc il a besoin de prouver qu'il
n'a pas été élu de l'extérieur comme les
démocrates le reprocher à traves donc en
ce sens il serait légitime et ça entre
donc dans une mise en scène avec un
journaliste qui pose une question qui
est manifestement préparé avec weiden
qui apporte une réponse qui est tout
aussi préparer donc on ne peut pas dire
si vous voulez que ce soit un moment de
pousser nerfs ont lâché un moment de
faiblesse non c'est réellement cela
s'ajoutent les deux pays
mais alors comment expliquer ça sachant
que les deux pays ont prolongé récemment
le traité new start 1 par exemple c'est
peut-être un signe d'apaisement là ça
change complètement
non je ne pense pas que le prolongement
du lieu de souhaiter sont un signe
d'apaisement c'est est nécessaire pour
les américains à ce moment là c'est tout
donc ils l'ont fait ils sont extrêmement
pragmatiques
leur stratégie est celle d'un isolement
total de la russie et c'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire en mettant en
place une rhétorique qui est la
rhétorique on utilise en temps de guerre
avec la diabolisation de l'ennemi avec
la nécessité de déshumaniser les nuits
et c'est exactement ce qui est en train
d'être fait actuellement par dieu byden
de façon tout à fait volontaire et
consciente présidente outil n'est pas un
président comment réagit la prescrivent
quelle réaction également de la part de
la population russe pour l'instant
effectivement c'est une réaction de choc
puisque en russie on estime que le
président est élu
à la différence de baden il a été
légitimement en russie donc c'est en
quelque sorte en une une a su qui est
faite à toute la population en russie
ainsi qu'aux instances
ce qui en revanche provoque si vous
voulez à mon avis un mouvement de
resserrement de la population derrière
le président russe et ce qui crédibilise
en revanche largement byden mais ce
qu'il ne change rien à la stratégie
américaine de d'isolement de la russie
en dénigrement de ce pays qui doit être
un pays paria sur la scène
internationale puisque les relations
inter étatiques ne sont pas alors
possible puisque les etats unis doivent
dominer uniquement eux le jeu
géopolitique et quelles réponses selon
fu possible pour la russie pour vladimir
poutine la russie doit avoir cette fois
ci une réponse forte et rapide c'est
possible forte dans le sens où il y à
une violation manifeste des règles de la
diplomatie
la russie ne peut pas continuer à rester
à se limiter dans le cas des règles
diplomatiques
elle doit aussi pourquoi pas dire tout
haut ce que tout le monde pense c'est à
dire que biden a effectivement été lu de
manière frauduleuse qui a énormément de
doutes sur la manière dont les élections
américaines sociaux avec une information
afp qui vient de tomber la russie a
rappelle son ambassadeur aux etats-unis
pour consultations
selon la diplomatie comment est-ce que
vous interprétez cet enfant qui tombe
donc à l'instant c'est justement une de
ses réponses fortes et rapides un qui
est tout à fait à propos puisque c'est
une rhétorique de guerre dans le cas
d'une rhétorique de guerre
il ya une rupture en tout cas montagne
suspension des relations diplomatiques
qui doivent trouver un autre fort marche
lorsque vous traitez le président d'un
pays de tueurs vous rompez defacto les
relations diplomatiques avec ce pays
sera présenté les excuses
merci car el béchir gologo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou